-Our first guest tonight is an
Oscar- and Emmy-nominated actor
you know him from shows
like "The Office" and
"The Morning Show," as well as
the films "The 40 Year
Old Virgin" and "Foxcatcher."
He stars in
"Minions: The Rise of Gru,"
which opens
in theaters July 1st.
Let's take a look.
-You seriously think a puny
little child can be a villain?
-Um, yes.
I am pretty despicable.
You don't want to cross me.
-Evil is for adults who steal
powerful ancient stones
and wreak havoc...
-[ Gasps ]
-...and not for tubby little
punks who should be at school.
-Please welcome to the show
Steve Carell, everybody.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
Welcome.
I'm so happy you're here.
-I'm so happy to be here.
It's a pleasure.
-You know, obviously,
you're this
accomplished comedian,
accomplished voice actor.
We first met in 2005
when you hosted "SNL."
And we wrote a sketch.
It was a Hurricane Katrina
celebrity benefit,
and we just assumed,
"We've got Steve Carell.
He must have a
million celebrity impressions."
That was not the case.
-Not the case.
-Yeah. And we literally said,
"It could be anyone."
-Right.
-And you said, "I have no one."
-I have -- I don't
do impressions. Terrible.
-And do you remember
what we came up with?
-Ray Romano.
-Yeah.
Now, I will say --
we have a still of it --
you ended up looking
more like Ray Romano
than I thought you could.
There's -- I'm Anderson Cooper,
and there you are.
That's a very...
-And I was terrified
because, you know,
I'd never done an impression,
and "SNL" is
predicated on impressions.
So, the first rehearsal,
I just kind of whipped out,
"Uh, yeah.
Uh, okay."
And that was it.
-Yeah.
-"I just kind of
did that to my voice.
Uh, Ray Romano. Uh, ha."
-I think that was
the extent of it, too.
-That was it.
-Yeah.
-I think everyone realized, "Oh,
we can't give him dialogue."
"Uh, yeah. How you doing?"
-It's better than I remember.
I will say, it's a lot better
than I remember.
-Yes.
-Yeah. Do people -- When you --
I mean, first of all,
this is a raised level of
difficulty here with this Gru.
Now you got to do a kid Gru.
-Oh, so hard.
-So hard?
-Oh, my gosh.
I'm being facetious.
-Do people ever --
-It's really not hard.
-Do people ever say to you,
"How do you come up with
your funny voices?"
-Never.
It just doesn't happen.
I think anyone can do Gru.
I really --
I shouldn't say that,
'cause I'll be out of a job.
-Because they could
probably get it.
-Well, I've been
doing this, like --
all this promotional stuff,
and one of them is, like,
people calling in
and trying to do the Gru voice.
And I coach them like,
"It's down here.
Hey, everybody!"
And people are quite good at it.
And Little Gru is just
more earnest and higher.
-Yeah.
-"He's kind of like this."
-Were you excited when
they told you
it was time to do Little Gru?
Did you think, "Oh, we're going
to switch it up a little bit"?
-Finally. Yeah.
No, I thought an origin story
was a good idea,
especially since
it's set in the '70s.
And just the nostalgia of that,
I think you can
really lean into it,
and I think parents are going to
really dig it --
grandparents, too.
-Well, that's the
really important thing about
when you make
these kids' movies.
The ones that I think
are beloved are ones
that adults can also enjoy.
So when you put anything in
there that they can hold on to,
because you can't send the kid
to go see Gru on their own --
-No, no.
-Yeah.
-Although, you know,
when my kids were little,
I used to sit and watch,
you know,
kids' shows with them,
and there were times that
they were out of --
They walked out of the room,
and I was still watching,
like, "iCarly,"
and I'm like,
"What's going to happen?"
And I enjoyed it.
-Did you worry
about your children
that they were so dismissive of
the outcome of "iCarly,"
her fate?
-No, I hadn't even
considered that.
I clearly don't
keep track of my kids.
-I know you to be
a man of great empathy,
and I want to ask you this,
because when you do press for
a movie like this,
you are often with Minions.
And when I say that --
You know, these are obviously --
I don't need to tell you,
these are people in
Minion suits.
-I've heard.
-Yeah.
And, Steve, a lot of times --
This is a summer film.
You're out -- It's pretty hot
when you're doing
"Minions" press.
-You know this day?
-Yeah.
-It was really hot.
And this other day,
it was the same.
Super-hot.
-Do you ever -- Can you ever
tell that the human beings
inside the Minion suits
are getting a little hot?
-Yeah. They start to
sputter a little bit.
We did this promo
where I did this soccer promo
with a soccer player from Mexico
named Chicharito.
And, so,
we did this a little bit,
and there were Minions
on his team
and these great, you know,
soccer players on my team.
And they were going to
have a soccer game.
And it was in L.A.,
and it had to have been
95, 100 degrees.
And these people in
the Minion suits were --
I mean, they're kicking the ball
and running around.
And where did the Minions go?
So, they had wrangled
the Minions around the corner,
where none of
the kids could see.
And all I saw, like, were
Minion costumes, sort of, like,
tipped over and, like,
arms and legs of human beings,
like, hiding behind bushes,
like, drinking water.
It was really -- It's --
Yes, it's a thankless job.
-It's a level of professionalism
that you have to appreciate
when you're inside --
when you're an actor
inside a Minion suit.
And you know you can't --
You can't lie down
in the middle of the field
because there are
a lot of kids there.
They don't want to see
a Minion go down.
-No, no. Exactly.
No, you have to -- You have to
keep your appearances up.
-What was your -- I mean, again,
it's weird when you do
a voice for an animated thing.
I mean, I'm sure, obviously,
you see drawings in advance,
but you don't see a
finished product
until a lot of people do.
What was it like the first time
you had the idea of Minions
explained to you?
-I thought,
"Good luck with that,"
because, well, they -- You know,
they showed me a picture,
and I thought,
"Well, sure, they're these
cylindrical yellow objects
that have --
either they have goggles,
maybe one eye, maybe two eyes."
It was explained to me
they don't speak English.
They speak in a gibberish.
So you can't really
understand them.
And they're hilarious.
I went, "Alright.
Well, good. Good for you guys.
That's a...
And it turned out to be
a stroke of genius.
Like, I saw that first movie.
I saw the finished product.
And you know, you're in a booth
and you're doing it
pretty much solitary.
You don't --
You never see any cuts of it.
You never -- You don't know what
the movie's going to
look like until you go see it.
And it was magical.
-Your early acting --
I did not realize this --
you did some -- like, some
Revolutionary War re-enacting?
-Jealous?
[ Laughter ]
-Now, you took this seriously.
You learned to play
an instrument.
-I did, yeah.
My brother and I joined --
I grew up in a town
outside of Boston,
and all of these little towns
had their own minuteman corps.
And it wasn't really
for re-enacting.
It's, like, mostly parades, and,
you know, the Fourth of July.
Back in Massachusetts, we have
something called Patriot's Day.
And, so, you know,
I wanted to be a part of it,
and so did my brother.
So he learned to play the drum,
and I learned
how to play the fife.
And, so, we got dressed up
in our little costumes
and we went out and marched
around, and that was kind of it.
Later on, I had acquired more of
an interest in history,
so I joined the
British Tenth Regiment of Foot,
which was much more serious.
And that's what I was --
like in high school.
And, like, they would cast
the buttons from the same molds
that the original buttons
were cast back then.
And so I kind of geeked out
and got into it.
-And did you have to have a
certain level of fife playing?
Was this the kind of group that
if you were shaky on the fife,
they wouldn't have you?
-If you could
kind of play the fife
and you were amenable
to dressing up like
a British grenadier,
they would have you.
-That's quite a good
advertisement for membership.
-It was. It was fun.
-Yeah.
It's a cool thing to do.
-No, it wasn't.
Don't say that.
I mean, everyone out there is
going, "Cool thing to do?
That kid must have been
a winner in high school."
[ Laughter ]
I enjoyed it.
-It worked out alright.
It worked out for you alright.
-It did.
And I can still play the fife.
-Can you really?
-Yes.
-Wow!
Have you had any reason to?
-"Wow!" That was the most
insincere "Wow."
-Yeah. "Wow!"
-"Wow!"
-Oh, my God! What's that?
Oh, no!
I got to go to commercial.
I'd love to hear
more about this fife.
-Fife? Wee!
-You guys, that's Steve Carell.
-I wish we had a fife!
-I wish we had a fife.
"Minions: The Rise of Gru"
is in theaters July 1st.
We'll be right back with
Machine Gun Kelly. Thank you.